I'm sure most of you go, and I don't have
to tell you that these are not particularly
bright days for the human race.
And there are multi level stories here.
There's the sort of full macro of the world
pandemic.
There's the micro of how or how our individual
lives are being affected.
And then sort of in the middle is how our
specific country is being led.
Or maybe more accurately, not led and lied
to daily by the president that we elected.
I would not me personally, not many of you
either, but as a country, this person that
we elected and we're going to be looking through
all of these multi level lenses and perspectives
today.
But I want to start with what is increasingly
the largest and most destructive source of
disinformation around the virus, which is
unfortunately, Donald Trump himself.
Donald Trump's press briefings, which we've
been covering live and I hope that you've
been joining me for some of them are riddled
with lies and attacks on journalists and are
pushing out actual doctors and scientists
who are trying to tell us the truth.
Trying to help the situation.
And instead filled with Donald Trump telling
lies and insulting people.
And the number of official cases in the United
States is exploding, of course.
The more we test, the more cases we find because
we've been so behind on testing, the number
of deaths is climbing every single day and
we can't even get straight answers about.
Have you sent ventilators to hospitals?
How many have you sent masks to hospitals
from the stockpile?
You talk about testing capacity coming online
every day.
You say by the end of the week, we will be
here.
And then at the end of the week we ask you
and you say, well, let's not really focus
on the numbers.
We are bringing on additional capacity.
And over the weekend, Donald Trump added worse
to worst by unleashing a historically unhinged
tweet storm riddled with propaganda and signaling
that the White House is fully switching from
50/50 propaganda and policy policy to deal
with the virus to exclusively propagandizing
around this pandemic crisis.
So let's look at some of the highlights.
And because Donald Trump has almost nothing
on his schedule these days other than a daily
briefing, usually one call with governors
or one call with FEMA.
Today, I looked at Trump's schedule this morning.
All he has is a briefing at 5:30 p.m. Eastern
today and lunch with Mike Pence.
That's it.
That's all that Donald Trump is doing.
He has a lot of time to tweet.
Trump tweeting a completely fact free video
from Fox News propagandist Jesse Waters with
the comment in all capital letters.
Chinese virus.
Fact check.
Trump attacking governors.
Trump attacking any governor who says, hey,
Trump might not be doing enough here.
Saying governor of Illinois and a very small
group of certain other governors together
with fake news, CNN and con cast calling Comcast,
Comcast, M.S.
DNC shouldn't be blaming the federal government
for their own shortcomings.
We are there to back you up should you fail.
And always will be in the midst of this.
Trump re-tweeting about 10 propaganda tweets
from Republicans.
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell also
riddled with disinformation and lies and political
posturing rather than dealing with the public
health.
To call it a crisis seems almost not strong
enough.
Trump then tweeting a thank you to right wing
extremist channel O Héléne One American
News, which has been tossing softball questions
at Donald Trump during the Corona virus hearings,
saying, thank you, Jen Pellegrino.
Oh n for throwing him a bogus question, of
course, about how everyone is just being so
unfair to him during the recent press briefing.
Now, this next one I want to be careful with
because it actually requires more analysis,
which we will do later.
Trump tweeting about a possible possible treatment
for the virus, saying hydroxy chloroquine
and a zit throw myson taken together, have
a real chance to be one of the biggest game
changers in the history of medicine.
Like, that's completely hyperbolic.
We're going to talk about that as a possible
treatment, but that's so hyperbolic.
Trump saying the FDA has moved mountains.
Thank you.
Hopefully they will both work.
Hydroxy chloroquine better with a zero Meissen.
International journal of anti-microbial agents
be put in use immediately.
People are dying.
Move fast and God bless everyone.
We'll deal with that in detail later.
So what we realized as if we didn't know it
from the last thirty eight months, what we
realized over the last three days is we're
in a real crisis.
Now, this is not at, you know, lying about
the deficit.
This is a real crisis.
We don't have a leader.
We have a confused.
70 year old man who has no idea what's going
on, doesn't listen to medical experts, thinks
he knows more, and this is not a game anymore.
Now, it already wasn't a game when kids were
in cages.
I understand that it hasn't been a game for
a while now, but there is a new dimension
in which this is no longer a game.
Trump needs to step away from covered.
Let Anthony Foushee take over.
Appoint Obama's Ebola czar Ronald Clain as
as covered czar. Trump must be removed from
the presidency, but if not that he has to
be distanced from the Koven fiasco.
And this is one of the things I want to dig
into now.